jigsaws infamous bathroom game didn't
play out quite like he drew it up in his
plans to hear about the key detail it
could have changed everything stick
around to the end of this video this
video is sponsored by the C's World
merch store welcome to another episode
of things you missed this week I want to
play a game so we'll be covering the
first major motion picture from James
Wan I feel like I've talked a lot about
Juan's work here on the channel and I
have talked about his franchises in
before but this is actually the first
time I've done a things you missed
specifically on a film that he directed
so the clock is ticking let's let the
game begin the first item of note comes
in before the movie even starts when we
see the twisted pictures logo animation
the company was started in order to
produce saw and the intro is inspired by
the razor wire trap which is the second
trap in the movie where a man named Paul
is asked to climb out of a cage riddled
with barbed wire and cut himself in
order to escape the movie itself opens
by showing us a little lights floating
around in the bathtub we don't know what
it is yet but if you look very closely
it's attached to the key to Adams
shackle which goes down the drain which
opens up when he wakes up in a panic and
saw three we find out that it was Amanda
who placed the key there and I think she
was supposed to put it somewhere else to
give Adam a chance to get it this means
that the game was designed with the
possibility of Adam being able to walk
freely around the bathroom and there's
more evidence of this later on dr.
Gordon is already awake at the beginning
of the movie and he demonstrates the
reason that jigsaw tested him his lack
of passion for life in his opening
dialogue enough that no point in yelling
he sounds defeated he sounds like he
doesn't care if he lives or dies
the goal of jigsaws game was basically
to change that to enlighten these
prisoners on the joys of life to
symbolize this enlightenment we see a
big booming shot of the overhead lights
literally turning on above them this
would also allow the glow-in-the-dark
paint to begin to charge the bathroom
itself is very strange
it's a dilapidated men's room but with
no dividers it looks commercial there
were multiple toilets sinks and showers
so the inclusion of a bathtub is strange
I think the bathtub represents jigsaws
idea of rebirth Adam awakes from it and
is thrust into the cold reality of the
bathroom just as we are born from the
womb into the harsh actuality of our
world we later learned that the bathroom
is located in a tunnel network
underground John was once an engineer
for low-income living solutions so I
wonder if the bathroom was once part of
some kind of communal shelter however
the signs seen in the tunnels at the end
of the movie says caution raus to it
though perhaps the bathroom was
connected to some kind of sewage
treatment center when Adam first noticed
John hiding in plain sight pretending to
be dead if he ironically makes an
observation first did body I've ever
seen different in real life which is a
nice touch
considering what happens in the final
scene and really adds to Adams sense of
terror after beginning to solve the
clues of the game
Adam obtains the tape recorder and puts
in his tape is a horrible human being
there is a little clue left on dr.
Gordon's tape about the identity of
jigsaw let's roll that clip
this is why we have to have social
distancing the coughing alludes to the
fact that Gordon already knows the
killer or at least he would have if he
had taken the time to appreciate the
human side of his dying patients his
name is John dr. Gordon it's a very
interesting person the other clue
whispered at the end of the tape
follow your heart leads Adam to find the
hacksaws as the audience we can see that
there's something else in the bag the
photos that Adam taken of dr. Gordon but
Gordon himself cannot see them
Gordon eventually realizes that he and
Adam may have been placed in the
bathroom by jigsaw the unknown serial
killer that dr. Gordon was once a
suspect for the cops who questioned him
are Stephen Singh and David Tapp and we
see a flashback of their first
encounters at jigsaw crime scenes
they're introduced to the remains of
Paul by Alison Carey one thing that I
found interesting is that her badge says
she's the deputy coroner and saw - she's
a homicide detective for the newly
formed serial killer task force so that
tells me that the loss of detectives
sing in tap resulted in her getting a
promotion there's also some important
information on the evidence bag telling
us the date that Paul was found was
March 19th 2004 this is shortly before a
six-month time skip which lands the date
of the bathroom games somewhere in
October of 2004 which is also when saw
was released were first introduced to
who John Kramer actually is in Gordon's
flashback at the hospital and John has
openly displayed his design sketch for
the reverse bear trap on the table just
like for anyone to see while he's asleep
I guess I mean if you're gonna be a
serial killer maybe don't do that but
just a suggestion if you do you might
want to hide the evidence just a little
bit I mean there's also a green X on the
opposite page perhaps symbolic of the x
marks the spot from the bathroom game
Gordon ends up being cleared as a
suspect but sticks around to hear the
testimony of the first survivor Amanda
who tells the story of how she woke up
in a room and the tape started playing
the upcoming ninth movie is called
spiral and the name draws inspiration
from the spirals on the cheeks of Billy
the puppet and later the large spiral
seen in John's workshop at the mannequin
Factory the spiraling camera movement
when John is first shown on screen you
know the one who he's pretending it to
be dead it could also be a connection in
my spiral trailer analysis I talked
about how I think the spiral can be kind
of like a new religious icon that
in Benton but I guess we'll have to find
out when the movie comes out when Amanda
goes to try to retrieve the key to the
reverse bear trap there's a secret
message from jigsaw hidden on the wall
if you pause at just the right moment
you can read it
[Music]
you
the message on the wall in Amanda's cell
reads if you try to keep your life for
yourself you will lose it but if you can
give your life to me you will find true
life this message doesn't seem to apply
to Amanda but it may have been part of a
previous game for a man described as
being her cell mates Donnie Greco Donnie
doesn't seem to have much of a chance to
survive he's essentially neutralized
when Amanda is forced to cut through his
stomach in order to retrieve her key
but jigsaw always believes in giving his
victims a second chance so I think
Donnie already lost his game and his
punishment was that he would now die in
Amanda's game this message was probably
part of the rules for Donnie's first
game when Amanda cuts open his stomach
the camera cuts to a shadow on the wall
a reference to a technique seen in early
German Expressionism films like one of
the earliest influential horror movies
ever Nosferatu I should also note that
many of the stylish techniques used in
Nosferatu were done to save money as
Germany was still picking up the pieces
from World War one at the time that it
was made saw was also made for a very
low budget but rather than picking up
the pieces from World War one the
producers of saw were picking up the
pieces of a second mortgage that they
had to put on their production
headquarters and luckily for them saw
ended up being very successful and
spawning many sequels
while those sequels may not have been
planned from the beginning I'd still
like to point out something that I found
interesting about Lawrence Gordon's home
this will contain spoilers for the
series so skip ahead 20 seconds if you
haven't seen the rest of the movies
Gordon has this clock in his living room
with these little ornaments that look
vaguely like jigsaw puzzle pieces this
gear could also represent the idea of
mechanical engineering as you may know
jigsaw was once a civil engineer and I
like to think that these could be little
clues that Lawrence Gordon would one day
make the perfect successor to jigsaw
there are clocks all over Gordon's house
including both an hourglass and analog
clock on his desk and that all ties into
part of the reason behind jigsaws work
time all of this starts when John finds
out from dr. Gordon how much time he has
to live when he learns that he learns
how valuable his time on earth really is
back in the present at the bathroom dr.
Gordon tells Adam about his favorite
picture of his family which all three of
them are in rare because someone usually
has to take the photo the shot is
missing from his wallet but I think we
actually do see it in his living room if
you pause during the chase at the end of
the movie I mean it makes sense
considering that this family just seems
to keep reusing the same few photos all
over the place over
and over and over the next flashback
shows bored and putting his daughter to
bed and he tries to calm her fears by
doing the this little piggy nursery
rhyme with her in John Kramer's mo pigs
represent rebirth that's why all of his
followers down the pig masks when
carrying out tasks for jigsaw after he
leaves his daughter sees that hiding in
the closet in what almost certainly
seems to be an homage to that scene from
black Christmas roll it
[Music]
meanwhile detective Tapp has been unable
to accept Lawrence Gordon's innocence
even after the doctor provides an alibi
and spies on him from a messy apartment
across the way what I cannot answer is
why detective Tapp has Amy's coffee
though what have you done to a me
detective tat yeah the apartment is a
mess and the walls are covered in
reconnaissance photos of the doctor and
newspaper headlines about the jigsaw
murders surprisingly none of the names
or authors mentioned in these articles
or Easter eggs or references to anything
there is one connection that would be
made retroactive Lee when saw the video
game was released in 2009 the author of
this article is as Walden McGillicuddy a
name that was given to the journalist
character that you save in the game
although the game is not considered
canon the actual contents of the article
as we often see in movies have nothing
to do with the headline this one's about
a toy called goofy clay that exploded
and destroyed a trailer home in Reno
the only other semi interesting tidbit I
found about these headlines was this
article which references Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey which
doesn't really have anything to do with
saw but is just a well-respected movie
in general there would be a more
meaningful reference shortly after when
singing tap discovered the location of
jigsaws hideout the map they used
doesn't seem to correlate to any
real-world locations that I could find
on Google Maps but they end up
determining that the fire alarm heard in
the tape must have been from an
emergency at two one three Stygian
streets Stygian Street is a reference to
James Juan's first independent film
Stygian and the address number two one
three is a reference to the area code of
lacy production Center where saw was
filmed when they arrived there the
workshop contained a miniature version
of the bathroom but dr. Gordon's shackle
is replaced with an electrical wire
which is connected to this battery this
is perhaps our first clue about the
electric shock components connected to
each of their chains jigsaw first used
this on Adam to ensure that he wasn't
cheating
[Music]
that Mount Gordon to try to snap him out
of his miserable wallowing and then
again on Adam to make him drop the gun
he was holding and then I'm the audience
because the ending was such a shocking
twist yeah okay I'll go off myself for
that pun John's workshop also provided
another clue about the true method that
Adam could have used to win and survive
the bathroom game
the reason that the miniature version of
the bathroom contains figures to
represent Gordon in jigsaw but not Adam
could be because when we see this it's
still six months before the game takes
place and Adam had not yet been hired to
photograph Gordon and so was not yet a
target of John Kramer however it's clear
that the game only works with the second
player so I think the fact that we don't
see Adam in this diagram is because of
what I mentioned near the beginning of
this video
Adam was supposed to have an opportunity
to retrieve his key and have the ability
to free roam around the bathroom and
possibly escape no I'm not saying he was
definitely supposed to get out of his
shackle otherwise why bother with the
whole electric shock component but it
seems like the freedom to move about may
have been something that Adam could have
earned also this may be the same
miniature used by the set designers of
the movie when they created the actual
bathroom because it actually says saw a
bathroom set right here guess we can
call this James Juan's coffee cup
moments Zep watches the game unfold from
a little area set up within Gordon's
home I noticed there's a microphone
there which makes me wonder if there was
ever supposed to be an aspect of the
game where Zep communicates with them
directly or maybe Zepp was just planning
on starting a little podcast the jigsaw
victim podcast let's see if I can top
that Bobby dagen Zep watches as Gordon
discovers the hidden box containing the
phone causing him to remember the night
that he was captured and every time I
watch it it makes me [ __ ] crazy I
mean why would Adam who is trying to
secretly spy on dr. Gordon use the flash
while taking photos of him I mean that
makes no sense that's just the dumbest
thing I've ever seen
I'm sorry I'm sorry but you're an idiot
Adam you're an idiot you know lawrence
becomes more and more suspicious of adam
secrets and rightfully so and asked what
else he may be hiding well let's see
on my sixth birthday my best friend at
the time Scot Tibbs stabbed me with a
rusty nail I didn't tell you about that
now on the DVD foresaw - there's a bonus
video called the Scot Tibbs documentary
which is a found footage short created
by Scots I had to find out more so I
cried this sweet little camera and I'm
making my own documentary about this
sick tip stop baby yeah it's not very
good okay it's it's kind of one of the
most embarrassing things I've seen a
professional film studio put out and
it's considered to be non-canon to the
saw story but I did want to bring it up
because if the character Scott himself
is still canon and there will be more
references to him in future things you
missed episodes when it comes down to
the end of the game Lawrence finally
caves in saws off his foot gets the
bullet and the gun but decides to try to
play dead trick with Adam one last time
this attempt was a little bit smarter
because it didn't require any acting
ability on Adams parts we all know how
that turned out last time I think
Lawrence gives the signal when the
camera cuts back to his head right here
when he probably winks at Adam the play
dead trick also calls back to earlier in
the film or jigsaw does the same thing
to trick saying it ends up being used
many times throughout the Saw franchise
so I'll be sure to point those out in
future episodes of things you missed the
movie ends with Gordon passing the test
and Adam failing to achieve his
enlightenment and as a result in jigsaw
locks in a way in the dark
but unlike all the sports leagues right
now whether it would be games to look
forward to in the future and I'm gonna
be covering them right here on Caesars
world join me next week for my first saw
episode of horror history and the next
episode of things you missed or I'll be
covering my personal favorite film in
the Saw franchise saw - if you love saw
you won't want to miss out on any of
that stuff so make sure you subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week bring that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
you